- So today, we're starting
in part three of the course
which I call the end
of the end of history.
And the end of the end
of history harken back to
the book, "The End of History"
that we talked about earlier.
What was this idea that democracy
and liberal institutions
and market capitalism had
come to the world to stay,
was embodied in the
neoliberal consensus at home
and the Washington Consensus abroad.
And as I have said several times,
I'm calling this the early
post Cold War period.
And so when I talk about the
end of the end of history,
when did the end of the end
of history happen in the US?
And the truth is it
didn't happen all at once
and it was a bit like turning around
a massive ocean liner at sea.
I would say that in the full consciousness
of mainstream elites,
it really ended with a bang
with the election of Donald Trump in 2016.
Even after Brexit, many people in America
didn't think that was heralding something
that might be happening here.
So I think that, but
then when that happened,
I think people started to realize
we were living in a different world
than the comfortable world
or the end of history
that we had come to identify.
But if you want to say when
did it really start ending
as opposed to when did
people realize it was ending,
I think that there was
a kind of bifurcation.
At home, it really starts,
I've dated it to the collapse
of Lehman Brothers on
September 15th of 2008
which was the beginning
of the financial crisis
which was gonna have huge knock on effects
for America's place in the global economy,
for the Washington Consensus.
There was gonna be this big retreat.
Russia and China,
as we're gonna talk about
this time next week,
would fill a big part of the void
as the Washington Consensus went home
or as the purveyors of the
Washington Consensus went home
and the consensus itself
started to disintegrate.
We started hearing about
the Beijing consensus,
and of alternative
development models, and so on.
So I think that was the beginning
of the collapse at home.
Abroad, when we think about geopolitics
rather than economics,
really it begins with,
I've dated it to the day
before the invasion of Iraq,
so March 19th 2003,
because I think that was
probably the high point
of American global geopolitical
influence in the world
for reasons that I'll talk about today.
So a little taking stock.
The Cold War had been won first of all
at a surprisingly low cost.
The Soviet Union had knelt down and died.
There was no big war.
It was a fairly peaceful transition
and in terms of blood and treasure,
much less than people
might have anticipated.
The 1990s and early 200s as I've just said
were the heyday of the
Washington Consensus
and democracy seemed to be on the march.
To remind you of a statistic
I told you about earlier,
at the turn of the 21st century
for the first time in human history,
there were more democracies in the world
than non-democracies.
So there's a lot of confidence in that.
9/11 gave the US huge leeway
to act internationally.
There was a very broad perception
that we had been a victim of
an justified terrorist attack,
not universal, but
extremely broad consensus
that the US certainly was going to do
what was necessary to chase down
the terrorists that had attacked us
and nobody was gonna
second guess that move
that we began in Afghanistan,
even if as it turned out later,
there were pause not taken
and things that might have
been done differently.
But it was a time of
unprecedented self confidence
in America's capacity to shape the world.
And perhaps this video of George W. Bush
on the 1st of May 2003 encapsulates
that self confidence about
as well as anybody could.
(engine rumbling)
(faint speaking)
(fanfare)
- In the outlaw regime that
has ties to terrorist groups
and seeks or possesses
weapons of mass destruction
is a great danger to the civilized world
and will be confronted.
(audience applauding)
We've begun the search for hidden chemical
and biological weapons,
and already know of hundreds of sites
that will be investigated.
Thanks, we like it.
Yeah, fantastic.
The transition from dictatorship
to democracy will take time
but it is worth every effort.
Our coalition will stay
until our work is done.
(faint speaking)
(laughing)
- So that sums it up
and another remarkable
statement of this was,
this was a comment made by an
anonymous White House aide.
Turned out later to be Karl Rove
to Ron Suskind, the journalist.
In October of 2004,
he had been complaining about a story
that Suskind had written
about Karen Hughes
who had been the White
House Press Secretary.
So Rove said to Suskind,
"You people seem to think
"that we have to start with reality,
"but we're an empire now and when we act,
"we create our own reality.
"And while you're studying that reality,
"judiciously as you will,
"we'll act again creating
other new realities
"which you can study too,
"and that's how things will sort out.
"We are history's actors,
"and you, all of you, will
be left to study what we do."
Right?
It's hard to say anything
stronger than that
about confidence in America's
capacity to shape reality.
And just again to make the contrast,
let's go back and see what
George W. Bush was saying
about US global strategic
ambitions and practices
three years earlier when he
was running for the presidency.
- Are we gonna step up
to the plate as a nation
the way we did after World War II,
the way that generation of heroes said,
"Okay, the United States
is gonna be the leader."
And the world benefited tremendously
from the courage that they
showed in those post war years.
- I'm not so sure the
role of the United States
is to go around the world
and say this is the way it's gotta be
'cause I am worried about
overcommitting our
military around the world.
I want to be judicious in its use.
I just don't think it's the
role of the United States
to walk into a country and say,
"We do it this way, so should you."
If we're an arrogant
nation, they'll resent us.
If we're a humble nation but strong,
they'll welcome us.
And our nation stands alone right now
in the world in terms of power,
and that's why we've got to be humble.
If we're an arrogant nation,
they'll view us that way,
but if we're a humble
nation, they'll respect us.
And so I don't our troops oughta be used
for what's called nation building.
I think what we need to
do is convince people
who live in the lands they
live to build the nations.
Maybe I'm missing something here.
I mean, we're gonna have kind
of a nation building core.
I'm concerned that we're
over-deployed around the world.
I don't want to be the world's policeman.
And the exit strategy
needs to be well defined.
- So what we see between
that speech in 2000
or those various clips from 2000
and the speech I showed
you last time from Rumsfeld
and the mission accomplished
speech and Rove's attitude
is a more or less complete take over
of the Republican administration
by the neoconservative wing
of the Republican party.
Now, I have talked about neoliberalism
and the Washington Consensus,
neoliberalism being the
commitment to the trifecta
of low regulation, free
trade, and privatization,
but I haven't talked about
neoconservatism yet in this course
and I'm here talking about today
the demise of the neoconservative dream,
but we need to be clear on
well, who were the neoconservatives
and what was their dream that demised
or came to its demise?
So here's some reflections
by Irving Kristol
who is widely known as the
godfather of neoconservatism.
- [Interviewer] Irving Kristol,
author of "The Autobiography
of an Idea: Neoconservatism."
When was the first time you
ever heard that word uttered?
- It must have been some
time in the mid 1970s.
It was not my term.
I did not invent it.
I believe it was invented by
someone who was criticizing me
and I thought that that
was a term of a (mumbles).
I decided that it was a
pretty good description
of in fact what I was
thinking and feeling,
so I ran with it.
- [Interviewer] What does it mean?
- What it means is that
it refers to a constellation
of opinions and views
that is not traditionally conservative,
but is conservative, and
is certainly not liberal.
Things, particularly
intellectual political things,
intellectual and political ideas
were more in flux in the 1970s
than either before or after.
That was the decade of transition
so far as I was concerned.
In 1968, I still voted
for Hubert Humphrey,
but by 1974, I realized I was
going to become a Republican.
And by that time, the term
neoconservatism had been invented
and I decided I was
also a neoconservative.
- You say that you've been a neo-Marxist,
a neo-Trotskyist, a
neosocialist, a neoliberal,
and finally, a neoconservative.
- That pretty much phrases
the trajectory of my political beliefs.
I've never been comfortable
with any of those doctrines
because I always saw problems
inherent in those doctrines.
Those who would 10 years ago
have been called neoconservatives
these days simply call
themselves conservatives.
The conservative movement
has expanded to include us.
- So there it is.
Now you know what neoconservatism was.
In fact, you can watch
that entire interview
from which I excerpted three minutes
and still not be able to glean.
You can glean what it wasn't,
but it's very hard to get
a sense of what it was.
But he nonetheless tells us
a couple of important
things about neoconservatism
that I think give clues to what it was.
To start at the end,
it was clearly something
that had gone mainstream
by the time he was talking in 1995.
So as he said, people were no longer
talking about neoconservatism as different
from mainstream conservatism by then.
But then the second clue is
his own personal history.
He started out on the left actually
as a kind of Trotskyist
critic of the Soviet Union
before World War II.
As information was coming out on the left,
people like the Webbs
and others in the UK,
there started to be a left
critique of the Soviet Union.
The people who ultimately
became the neoconservatives
sometimes were called liberal hawks.
And they very much, another
one much later actually,
people called Christopher
Hitchens a neoconservative
for his support for the Iraq War.
So it had a long lineage
and its roots were in the pre World War II
criticism of the USSR.
And in the '60s and '70s,
it was fueled by people,
a lot of whom had started out
in the sort of Scoop Jackson Democrats
who didn't like the peace movement,
didn't like the peace nix.
They didn't like the new
left, didn't like the '60s,
and all of that.
And they tended to ally themselves
with the proponents of rollback
in various administrations,
so in Republican administrations,
and they certainly were a lot
closer to Nixon's policies
than they were to the Democrats
who came subsequently.
So they were for aggressive
prosecution of the Cold War,
staunchly anti-communist
and anti-socialist.
In the post Cold War period,
of course, like everyone else,
the neoconservatives were rethinking
what their views should
be in this new world
since their sort of
raison d'etre for decades
had been virulent anti-communism
and communism for all practical
purposes had gone away.
And this is when the
neoconservatives I think
started to differentiate themselves
from other conservatives,
certainly from libertarian conservatives
and people who were
subsequently critics of theirs
come to be called paleoconservatives
or to call themselves paleoconservatives
'cause they didn't like being identified
with the neoconservative label.
And the distinctive feature
of the post Cold War
neoconservatives were two, I think.
One is that they wanted
to spread democracy around the world.
They were interested in knocking
off non-democratic regimes,
but they also didn't doubt for a second
that democratic regimes
would be pro-American.
So they really were if you like,
we might say today drinking the Kool Aid
of the early post Cold War consensus,
but they thought that installing democracy
in the Middle East or anywhere else
would automatically produce regimes
that were friendly to the US.
And indeed, just to give
two illustrations of that.
One of the justifications
for the invasion of Iraq
was that it would be a
positive domino process.
We would democratize Iraq
and we would get a friendly
western style regime there
and then that would have
knock on effects either.
And partly because that didn't happen,
there was huge pressure to
conduct elections in Lebanon
even though all the
experts were telling them
it would actually strengthen the position
of the anti-American militias.
Or you can see in 2005 and six,
they pushed strongly for elections
in the West Bank and Gaza
and were stunned when Hamas
won the elections in Gaza.
So there'd been this expectation.
Not only is it easy to implant democracy,
but democracies will tend to
see the US as a benign force
and will be pro-American.
And they were people like Eliot Abrams,
Richard Perle, Paul Wolfowitz,
and Cheney who had been
the defense secretary
in George Herbert Walker
Bush's administration
and would come back with George W. Bush,
and of course, Donald Rumsfeld.
And if you want to find a defining example
of neoconservative thinking,
it's this document published in 1995
called "From Containment
to Global Leadership:
"America and the World
After the Cold War,"
written by this man Khalizad
who is currently by the way
Pompeo's envoy to Afghanistan
and he served in multiple administrations
in various capacities,
but he produced this document in 1995
basically in which he said
in the post Cold War era,
America's got three
options geopolitically.
It can go back to isolationism.
He called it neoisolationism.
People like this neo word.
I don't know what the difference
between neoisolationism and isolationism.
One is you withdraw from the world
and the other is you
withdraw from the world, but.
(audience laughing)
The other would be to go
back to pre World War II,
a multi-polarity where it
was all about balancing,
much of the sort of balancing
that had gone in even in
the 19th century in Europe.
And he made a case that
both of those things
would be very bad for the US,
and instead, we should take
a global leadership role,
and this is the key
claim in the report was
or the document was that he advocated
that the use of force and even
preemptive war if necessary
to preserve US global hegemony.
And so this is what differentiated
the neoconservatives
from other conservatives.
And it was that document
that really became the forerunner
for the 2002 and 2006
national security strategies
that were embodied in the Bush doctrine
that we talked about last time.
So that's the sort of main elements
of the neoconservative creed
and the history or the
biography of it, if you like.
So intellectuals have ideas,
but how did they become
important in politics?
And as with the neoliberal views,
it goes back to think tanks.
I mentioned to you when
we were talking about
the resurgence of the Republican right
that after the Nixon administration
fell apart in the 1970s,
there was this emergence
of activist think tanks
who were committed not to
winning the next election,
but rethinking the conservative
agenda for the medium term
funded by Fulner, Koch,
and others in places
like The Heritage Foundation,
The Cato Institute,
and related conservative think tanks
who were mostly interested
in domestic politics,
particularly rolling back the frontiers
of the welfare state.
And they got their great moment in 1994
when the Republicans took over the house
for the first time in four decades
and Newt Gingrinch set himself up
as a kind of prime
minister on Capitol Hill.
Had Bill Clinton on the run
having lost the midterm elections badly.
And that was the opening
and we've been through that,
the contract with America and all of that.
But there was also a
geopolitical rethinking
among these people
we're talking about now,
and I'm calling it the neoconservatives.
And they were also in think tanks.
Some of them in not particularly
partisan think tanks
like the Rand Corporation
which is where that document
I just read from came out,
and the Council on Foreign Relations
which certainly billed
themselves as nonpartisan
even if many people saw them
as sort of right of center.
But then places like the
American Enterprise Institute
which are sort of activist
conservative think tanks.
People like Perle were there
and a number of the other neoconservatives
spent a lot of time there.
And then perhaps most
important was a new think tank
created in 1997 by Bill Kristol,
that's Irving Kristol's son,
and Robert Kagan, the son of our colleague
Professor Kagan here in
the history department.
And the Project for a New American Century
was probably the prime
incubator of neoconservatism
and many people who subsequently wound up
in the Bush administration
spent time there
were passing through these think tanks.
And really, 9/11 was their moment.
9/11 was the moment at which they realized
that there was a huge vacuum
in thinking about US strategic policy
and they could go for it.
And as I think I mentioned
to you last time,
by December of 2001,
I'm sorry, by December of 2000,
there were already conversations going on,
I'm sorry, 2001,
December of 2001,
there were already conversations
going on in the White House
as to when they could reallocate troops
from Afghanistan to Iraq.
Now, many people might say,
well, why did anybody
really want to attack Iraq?
It seems something of a puzzle.
The neoconservatives
had this view about it,
but we really have to back into it
and look a little bit at the
historical background here.
So after Saddam Hussein was
kicked out of Kuwait in 1991,
I described the containment regime
that the Bush administration constructed
with the no fly zones and
oil for food and all of that
that was essentially meant
to hem Saddam Hussein in.
They rejected regime change and so on.
They rejected internally
externally imposed regime change,
but the George Herbert
Walker Bush administration
was by no means opposed to fomenting
the overthrow of Saddam Hussein's regime,
just didn't want to commit
American troops to that.
And indeed, one of the things
he was greatly criticized for at the time
was encouraging the Shiites in the south
and the Kurds in the north
to overthrow Saddam Hussein.
But when they made those efforts,
there was no US backup and support
and that led to the
slaughter of many of them
by the (mumbles) regime.
And beyond that, the CIA
in the years following
spent a lot of time and resources
working with opposition groups in Iraq
and expatriate groups outside of Iraq
to try and engineer the
overthrow of that regime
even though it wouldn't involve
American boots on the ground.
And indeed, there was the creation
of something called the
Iraqi National Congress
led by a man called Ahmed Chalabi
who was an Iranian expatriate
who had been living in London for decades.
He hadn't been in Iraq
for a very long time.
And he worked very closely with the CIA
and others to get
American indirect support
for overthrowing the Iraqi regime.
They put together this
Iraqi National Congress
which was basically an
umbrella organization
to try and get all the opposition
groups in Iraq together
and figure out how to knock
off the Saddam Hussein regime.
This was formed in 1992.
By 1994, it was falling apart in acrimony.
The two Kurd groups were fighting
over the control of different
parts of the country,
mostly having to do with oil,
and some of them were actually working
with Saddam Hussein's regime.
Chalabi convinced the US
nonetheless to persist
with the kind of remnants of
the Iraqi National Congress
which he headed
and ultimately became a
political party in the new Iraq.
And he convinced the US, the
Clinton administration in 1995,
to sponsor an attempt at overthrowing,
sort of Clinton's I guess
little under publicized,
but Clinton's kind of bay of pigs
in that Chalabi predicted and promised
that as soon as this got going,
the Iraqi military would welcome it
and they would overthrow Saddam
and they would liberate Iraq.
It was quickly put down.
100 people were executed,
many more imprisoned,
but it didn't end the love affair
between the Clinton administration
and particularly the
neoconservatives in these think tanks
and Ahmed Chalabi who
constantly worked to raise money
and to get support for
overthrowing the regime.
However, the Clinton administration
wasn't that interested in this.
It was basically being dragged along
by the conservatives who now
controlled congress after 1994.
Clinton was basically enforcing
the containment regime
that his predecessor had put in place.
So for example, in December of 1998,
there were three days of
bombing Saddam Hussein
which he described as follows.
- Three days ago,
despite clear warnings
from the United States
and the international community,
Iraqi forces attacked and seized
the Kurdish controlled city
of Erbil in Northern Iraq.
Limited withdrawals announced by Iraq
do not change the reality.
Saddam Hussein's army today controls Erbil
and Iraqi units remain
deployed for further attacks.
These acts demand a strong response
and they have received one.
Earlier today, I ordered
American forces to strike Iraq.
Our missiles sent the following
message to Saddam Hussein.
When you abuse your own people
or threaten your neighbors,
you must pay a price.
Our objectives are limited, but clear,
to make Saddam pay his price
for the latest act of brutality,
reducing his ability to
threaten his neighbors
and America's interests.
First, we are extending the
no fly zone in Southern Iraq.
This will deny Saddam
control of Iraqi airspace
from the Kuwaiti border to the
southern suburbs of Baghdad
and significantly restrict Iraq's ability
to conduct defensive
operations in the region.
Second, to protect the
safety of our aircraft
enforcing this no fly zone,
our cruise missile struck Saddam's
air defense capabilities in Southern Iraq.
Saddam Hussein's objectives may change,
but his methods are always the same.
Violence and aggression against the Kurds,
against other ethnic minorities,
against Iraq's neighbors.
Our answer to that recklessness
must be strong and immediate.
As President Bush demonstrated
in Operation Desert Storm,
as we showed two years ago
when Iraq mast its forces
on Kuwait's border,
and as we showed again today,
we must make it clear that
reckless acts have consequences
or those acts will increase.
We must reduce Iraq's ability
to strike out at its neighbors
and we must increase America's ability
to contain Iraq over the long run.
- So there you see
he's speaking the language of containment.
They called it aggressive containment.
It was the sort of policy he's
talking about in that clip.
But the neoconservatives weren't happy
with aggressive containment.
You might think of them
as the latter day proponents of rollback.
Indeed as mentioned last week,
the Bush doctrine was
really about rollback
of aggression of any sort
to anywhere in the world
at the time of America's choosing.
So the neoconservatives weren't happy
with aggressive containment
and pushed the passage of something
called The Iraq Liberation Act of 1998.
The Iraq Liberation Act of 1998,
just to give you some sense
of how much the democrats here
were either on the run
or lacking in an alternative
conception of their own,
a point to which I will return,
the act passed 360 to 38 in the house
and by unanimous consent in the senate.
And that act declared
that it was a policy of the United States
to support efforts to remove the regime
headed by Saddam Hussein.
So clear commitment of the
United States government
to overthrowing the regime.
It authorized 87 million dollars
to support seven designated groups
and it created the opportunity
to support more of them
with the clear beneficiary
that everyone had in mind
was The Iraqi National Congress.
And this would be cited by the
Bush administration in 2002
in justification of the upcoming invasion.
But let's just parse
the Iraq Liberation Act
a little more closely again
by watching Bill Clinton that same day,
from a little later that same day
than the earlier clip I showed you.
- This crisis also demonstrates
unfortunately once again
that Saddam Hussein remains an impediment
to the well being of his people
and a threat to the peace of his region
and the security of the world.
We will continue to contain
the threat that he poses
by working for the elimination
of Iraq's weapons of mass
destruction capability
under (mumbles),
enforcing the sanctions
in the no fly zone,
responding firmly to
any Iraqi provocations.
However, over the long term,
the best way to address that threat
is through a government in Baghdad,
a new government that is committed
to represent and respect its people,
not repress them,
that is committed to peace in the region.
Over the past year,
we have deepened our engagement
with the forces of change in Iraq,
reconciling the two largest
Kurdish opposition groups,
beginning broadcasts of a radio free Iraq
throughout the country.
We will intensify that effort,
working with congress to
implement The Iraq Liberation Act
which was recently passed,
strengthening our political support
to make sure the opposition,
or to do what we can
to make the opposition
a more effective voice
for the aspirations of the Iraqi people.
- So there you can see
he's still talking the
language of containment
even while addressing
The Iraqi Liberation Act.
Notice the date.
The date's a significant one,
December 19th 1998,
and it explains the kind of
deer caught in the headlights
look on Bill Clinton's face
because that was the day
that the house voted to impeach him.
So he was not a happy
camper, one might say,
on that day while making that speech.
So this was the tussle
that went on toward the
end of the administration.
And the Clinton Administration
was never ever contemplating
actually going in and overthrowing.
In fact, of the 87 million dollars,
only eight was ever allocated
by the end of the administration.
So they were largely
going through the motions
and he was running scared of
the Republicans in congress.
And so what happens after that
is that these ideas are all rolling around
in the conservative think tanks
and being pushed by Chalabi,
but they're not really
making their way into,
as you see, they didn't make their way
into the political
campaign of George W. Bush.
And when 9/11 came along,
they thought this is our moment,
and it was their moment.
And it was then produced
a huge conflict within the administration
because on the one hand,
you had the Pentagon
largely allied with Chalabi
who wanted to go in,
but the State Department
and the CIA were strongly
opposed to going in.
And indeed, they said that
most of the intelligence
that they saw, if not all of it,
did not show any connection
between Saddam Hussein's regime and 9/11,
or that there was any active program
of building weapons of
mass destruction in Iraq
which were two of the war aims
most commonly cited in the
quest to go in to Iraq.
In the Pentagon on the other hand
is where the neoconservatives were.
And they were working with intelligence
that was largely provided
for them by Chalabi
which turned out later to be fake news.
And this was the fight that was going on
and that once 9/11 occurred,
the Pentagon people and
the neoconservatives
basically got into the
driver's seat and took over
partly because both Rumsfeld and Cheney
were sympathetic to their goals
and already in the administration.
And so we had this invasion of Iraq
that was a colossal
catastrophe for America.
It was a colossal catastrophe
on a number of fronts
and I would say that just
to give some statistics,
first of all, in terms of US casualties,
it should be 4,970.
I'll fix that slide.
Almost 5,000 killed, 32,000 wounded.
Between 150,000 and 600,000
Iraqis, I'll fix that too,
killed depending on which
estimates you go with.
They had given as one of the
reasons for going into the war
was that the cost of containment,
but of course, it was nickels and dimes
compared to the 1.9 trillion
that the CBO was predicting
the war would cost in 2007
and now, our colleague
Bill Nordhaus has a paper
estimating it costed in excess
of three trillion dollars.
So the financial cost was just enormous
and it was a massive display
of American weakness.
And this is why I mentioned
the date before the invasion
as the key date if you want
to pinpoint the high point
of American influence in the region.
It was a massive display of
American weakness in two senses.
One was that the US couldn't in fact,
the US couldn't win this war in any sense
that would enable them
to live up to the mission accomplished
that George Bush had announced on May 1st.
So what they conflated was the capacity
to destroy a country's army
with the capacity to actually
pacify and govern a country,
to win a piece, if you like.
And so they put in a barely
competent general very early on
and he couldn't run the country.
They replaced him with Paul
Bremer, a neoconservative,
and he began by disbanding the Iraqi Army
and officer corps in particular
because they were Sunni
and the majority of the
population were Shiite,
and disbanding the Iraqi civil service
out of fear that they might
be loyal to Saddam Hussein.
And so it effectively
created a failed state
that descended into civil war.
They discovered that their
investment in Ahmed Chalabi
had been extremely ill conceived
because not only did he
give them bad intelligence
as he had been doing
all the way back to 1995
in the Clinton Administration,
he predicted that the Americans
would be greeted with
flowers in the streets
and that we would have no difficulty
creating a democracy in Iraq.
And interestingly enough,
they immediately appointed him president
of the transitional
governing council in Iraq.
But when the 2005 elections
were finally held,
they had by then appointed
him deputy president
or deputy prime minister
and minister of oil,
he didn't even win a seat in the elections
and so he had to leave the government.
And he subsequently became involved
in a variety of corrupt schemes
and fell out of favor with the Americans
and finally died I believe in 2015.
So it was a massive display
of American weakness
in that sense as well.
And it's a lesson that
proponents of rollback
failed to learn again,
and again, and again,
and that I mentioned to you last week
which is that you can destroy
a country's army perhaps,
but destroying people's capacity to fight
when they have everything at stake
and you're fighting an elective war
is a very tough proposition.
So this massive display
of American weakness,
the domino theory didn't work.
Not only were we not getting democracy
of any functioning sort in Iraq,
but it was not spreading
elsewhere in the Middle East.
And you might wonder to yourself why?
Why would the neoconservatives believe
you could create democracies
in these countries
that had no history of democracy?
And I think that the puzzle there
is less difficult to understand
if you think back to what
they were looking at.
What they were looking
at was Eastern Europe
after the collapse of communism.
All of those countries that had
been occupied by the Soviets
or had been occupied by the Soviets
and then run by Soviet puppet regimes,
as soon as the Soviets fell apart,
democracy sprang up.
There wasn't any difficulty
in getting democracy installed
across Eastern Europe.
And so they thought well,
that's what happens.
You get rid of the oppressive dictator
and you create a democracy
and everything will be hunky dory.
And not only that,
those democracies in Eastern Europe
were largely pro-American.
And so the conflation
of creating a democracy
and having a pro-American regime
you might say was understandable.
What they were ignorant of
I think were several things
and they would have had much better clues
if instead of looking at Eastern Europe
where they were fairly
developed diversified economies
everywhere except Albania
that had prewar histories of
democracy in many of them,
they should have looked at
the (mumbles) former
republics of the Soviet Union
to think about what was likely to happen
when the Soviet Communist
systems disintegrated.
And of course, there,
there had not been
transitions to democracy.
And those were countries with
much lower per capita income.
We know that that's
important for democracy.
They were undiversifiable,
countries like Kazakhstan
which is largely just an oil economy.
So no diversification.
If they had a high per capita income,
it was oil curse high per capita income.
So it was undiversified economy.
We know that's not propitious
for democracy either.
So for all of these reasons,
it was really pie in the sky to believe
that you could just get
democracy to spring up.
And indeed, if you think back
to the two most successful cases
of externally imposing
democracy on a country,
we have to go back to
the post World War II
West Germany and Japan
which were very unusual
for a number of reasons.
One was that the populations themselves
blamed their prior regimes
for bringing disaster upon them, right?
In 2003 in Iraq,
the Iraqi population did
not blame Saddam Hussein
for the American invasion,
whereas the Germans and Japanese
had started aggressive wars
and so they recognized
they had themself to blame.
They were occupied for decades
by either occupying
forces or hovering forces.
They were protected by the US
umbrella during the Cold War.
They were supported economically
by the Marshall Plan
and of course, they had
favorable demographics
for reasons I talked to you
about some lectures ago.
None of these conditions
were remotely present
in the countries in the Middle East
that the Bush Administration
was hoping for
and the neoconservatives
were hoping would produce
a domino effect of successful
pro-Western democracies
across the regions.
So all of these were costs
of the invasion of Iraq,
but perhaps the greatest
cost of the invasion
was a loss of moral high
ground on the global stage.
- Last month, the US Army
announced 17 soldiers in Iraq
including a brigadier general
had been removed from duty
after charges of
mistreating Iraqi prisoners.
But the details of what happened
have been kept secret until now.
It turns out photographs surfaced
showing American soldiers abusing
and humiliating Iraqi prisoners
at a prison near Baghdad.
Americans did this to an Iraqi prisoner.
According to the US Army,
the man was told to stand on
a box with his head covered
with wires attached to his hands.
He was told that if he fell of the box,
he would be electrocuted.
Abu Ghraib Prison under
Saddam Hussein was infamous.
For decades, many who were
taken here never came out.
And those prisoners who did make it out
told nightmarish tales of
torture beyond imagining
and executions without reason.
Abu Ghraib was the centerpiece
of Saddam's empire of fear.
We talked about the prison
and shared pictures of
what Americans did there
with two men who have extensive
interrogation experience,
former US Marine Lieutenant
Colonel Bill Collin,
and former CIA Bureau Chief Bob Bayer.
- I visited Abu Ghraib a couple
days after it was liberated.
It was the most awful
sight I've ever seen.
And I said if there's ever a reason
we want to get rid of Saddam Hussein,
it's 'cause of Abu Ghraib.
There are bodies that were eaten by dogs,
torture, electrodes coming out of walls,
scratches.
It was an awful place.
- We went into Iraq to stop
things like this from happening,
and indeed, here they are
happening under our tutelage.
- It was American soldiers
serving as military police as Abu Ghraib
who took these pictures.
The investigation started
when one soldier got them from a friend
and gave them to his commanders.
We have a dozen of them.
There are many, many more.
The pictures show Americans,
men and women in military uniforms
posing with naked Iraqi prisoners.
There are shots of the
prisoners stacked in a pyramid,
one with a slur written
on his skin in English.
In some, the male prisoners are positioned
to simulate sex with each other.
And in most of the pictures,
the Americans are
laughing, posing, pointing,
or giving the camera a thumbs up.
One of the soldiers facing court marshal
is Army Reserve Staff
Sergeant Chip Frederick.
He is charged with maltreatment
for allegedly participating
in setting up this photo
and for posing in a photograph
sitting on top of a detainee.
Sergeant Frederick is also
charged with an indecent act
for observing this scene.
He is charged with assault for
allegedly striking detainees
and ordering detainees
to strike each other.
Sergeant Frederick's letters
and email messages home
offer clues to problems inside the prison.
Frederick wrote that he was
helping the interrogators.
Quote, military
intelligence has encouraged
and told us great job.
They usually don't allow others
to watch them interrogate,
but since they like the
way I run the prison,
they've made an exception.
We help getting them to talk
with the way we handle them.
We've had a very high rate
with our style of getting them to break.
They usually end up breaking within hours.
According to the Army's own investigation,
that's what was happening.
The Army found that interrogators
asked reservists working in the prison
to prepare the Iraqi detainees physically
and mentally for questioning.
Attorney Gary Meyers and
a judge advocate in Iraq
are defending Chip Frederick.
They say he should never have been charged
because of the failure of his commanders
to provide proper training and standards.
How could such a person
described almost universally
by people who knew him as a good guy
get himself into this kind of jam?
- The elixir of power,
the elixir of believing
that you're helping the CIA for god's sake
when you're from a small town in Virginia,
it's intoxicating.
And so good guys sometimes do things
believing that they
are being of assistance
and helping a just cause
and helping people who
they view as important.
- Sergeant Frederick says
he didn't see a copy of
the Geneva Convention rules
for handling prisoners of war
until after he was charged.
The Army investigation confirms
that soldiers at Abu Ghraib
were not trained at all
in Geneva Convention rules.
Frederick says there were
far too few soldiers there
for the number of prisoners.
About how many prisoners were there?
- [Chip] There was, when I
left, there was over 900.
And there was only five soldiers
plus two non-commissioned
officers in charge
for those over 900 inmates.
- That may have been
a contributing factor,
but at the end of the day,
this is probably more about
leadership, supervision,
setting standards, abiding
by the army values,
and understanding what's right
and having the guts to say what's right.
- I see a lot of work
going on out here now.
We're changing everything.
- [Dan] This is Brigadier
General Janis Karpinski
who ran Abu Ghraib for the Army.
She was also in charge of three
other Army prison facilities
housing thousands of Iraqi inmates.
The Army investigation determined
that her lack of leadership
and clear standards
led to problems system wide.
General Karpinski talked
with 60 Minutes Steve Kroft
last October at Abu Ghraib
before any of this came out.
- And this is international standards.
It's the best care available
in a prison facility.
- But the Army's own investigation
found serious problems behind the scenes.
The Army has photographs
that show a detainee with
wires attached to his genitals
and another that shows a dog
attacking an Iraqi prisoner.
Were dogs ever used on the inmates?
- [Chip] Yes, sir.
They were used for intimidation factors.
- [Dan] And then there is
this picture of an Iraqi man
who appears to be dead and badly beaten.
- Dan, I'd like to sit here and say
these are the only prisoner abuse cases
that we're aware of,
but we know that there
have been some other ones
since we've been here in Iraq.
- [Dan] When Saddam
Hussein ran this prison,
Iraqis were too afraid
to come to Abu Ghraib
and ask for information
on their family members.
When we were there last month,
hundreds had gathered outside the gates
worried about what's going on inside.
(woman sobbing)
(people chattering)
- We will be paid back for this.
These people at some
point will be let out.
Their families are gonna know.
Their friends are gonna know.
- [Dan] This is a hard
story to have to tell
when Americans are
fighting and dying in Iraq.
- So it's hard to overstate the shock
that that caused at home,
but the biggest cost I think
of Abu Ghraib was not at home
but it was the loss of
the moral high ground
that the US had enjoyed until
that time across the region.
If you look at the polling
across much of the Middle East
about perceptions of the
US during this period,
I described it in the reading
that I assigned for today,
it fell off a cliff.
And the notion that the US
was in some sense bringing a better world
and had different kinds of practices
was this sort of flagrant
violation of Canon's dictum
that we should not behave in the way
that our adversaries behave
and that the long term
strategy of containment
is for the hearts of minds
of people in the countries
that are being contained.
And of course, the fact that
this was all exposed in,
initially, this 60 Minutes
report was in April of 2004,
but the following month,
Seymour Hersh published a
huge expose in The New Yorker
where he had gotten hold
of the Army's report
which you saw referred to in that clip
which revealed that they had known about
what was going on in Abu Ghraib
and a number of other
prisons for many months.
And the story just didn't get any better.
What turned out to be the case
in terms of prosecutions were minimal.
The general you saw there
was busted back to a colonel.
There was some other
disciplinary actions of officers.
Nobody above the rank of staff sergeant
was convicted of any criminal offense
and only I think it was
seven or eight people
had any kind of criminal convictions,
the highest being a 10 year sentence.
So the perception was
that the US had allowed
the same kind of abominable practices
that Saddam Hussein had engaged in
and as I said,
the cost in terms of
loss of moral high ground
is probably incalculable to this day.
What made it even worse was
that President Bush announced
that the prison would be
closed the following year
which was not done,
and in fact,
it wasn't closed until
after the Americans left.
A decade later, it was
closed by the Iraqis.
So this combination of a
demonstration of American weakness
and the loss of any kind of
claim to be acting in defense
of humanitarian ideals was destroyed.
In a geo-strategic sense though,
I think the biggest cost
and some might in some
sense call it a benefit
of the Iraq debacle was it
was a clear demonstration
that the Bush doctrine was unsustainable
because the idea that you
could go around the world
knocking off regimes.
This is the neoconservative dream,
turns out to be a nightmare
because you go around the
world knocking off regimes
unless you have the
propitious circumstances
and the kinds of investments
that we made in Germany and
Japan after World War II.
The high probability
is you're going to get
the sort of outcome that we saw in Iraq.
And so the Bush doctrine
particularly given that
it's being prosecuted
in an era of cutting
back government spending
and downsizing the
military as Rumsfeld argued
in the clip I showed you
at the beginning of
last Thursday's lecture
and contracting out more and
more military activities,
you're not gonna be able
to go around the world
doing the sort of thing
we were trying to do
in Iraq and Afghanistan
and end up with,
as Bush says in the clip
I showed you earlier,
a clear exit strategy.
And indeed, the Bush doctrine
was a complete repudiation
of the so-called Powell Doctrine
of you've got to go in
with overwhelming force
and a clear exit strategy.
Instead, it's proxy
wars fought on the cheap
using expatriates and local militias
who have very different
agendas than one's own
and this is the result
that you shouldn't be surprised to see.
But if not the Bush doctrine, what?
If not the Bush doctrine, what?
Because the 1995 document from Rand said
what are the alternatives here?
The alternatives seem to be
neoisolationism as he called it,
going back to a multi-polar world
where in an era of nuclear proliferation,
that seems very dangerous
and costly for the US.
So you might say well,
where were the Democrats?
We have a democracy here.
We have an opposition party
and one would expect
that the opposition party
would be articulating
an alternative vision.
And the Democrats though were
completely on the defensive.
So here, I should give
you a personal anecdote.
In September of 2008,
I was invited to speak
at the Yale Club of Tokyo
to a group of alumni.
We do that all the time.
We're asked to go and
talk about our research.
So I answered with three possible topics
of things I was then working on
that I would be willing to speak out.
And the answer came back
that nobody would be
interested in any of them.
(audience laughing)
And what they wanted me to speak about
was what the Kerry Administration's
foreign policy was going to be.
This is September of
2000, I'm sorry, 2004.
What the Kerry Administration's
foreign policy was going to be.
So I ended up giving a talk on
why there wasn't gonna
be a Kerry Administration
and the central thesis of that talk
was you can't beat something with nothing.
And the reality here,
you can see if you now
go back over the lecture
that I've just given you.
You can see the clues
that the Democrats really
had no alternative.
First of all, think about that vote
of The Iraq Liberation Act.
I said it was only 50 or 60
votes against it in the house,
unanimous consent in the senate,
and Clinton signs it into law
in the midst of his impeachment hearings.
The 87 million dollars
that I mentioned to you
that they authorized for spending
on opposition forces in Iraq,
that is the famous 87 million
that Kerry was later got
into trouble for saying
well, I voted for the 87 million dollars
before I voted against it.
And was used in ads against
him by President Bush
when he was running for
re-election that year.
And if you look at the
votes to authorize the war,
Kerry had voted for the authorization
of the invasion of Iraq in 2003
as had by the way Hillary Clinton.
And so basically what was going on
was that the Democrats were
playing a game of triangulation.
And as we saw when we talked about
the anti-tax movement
in domestic politics,
the trouble with triangulation
is that it's good tactics
and it's bad strategy.
It's good tactics
because if you move towards
your opponent's position,
you can peel off some of their support
and people on your flank
really have no place to go.
That was the theory behind it.
But the reason it's bad strategy
is that once your opponent figures out
that this is what you're doing,
their incentive is to move the goal posts.
And so in effect, the Republicans
and particularly the neoconservatives
within the Republican party
had the Democrats on the run
because they were playing triangulation
to catch up to this target
that was moving steadily
in a neoconservative direction.
The same thing happened
as happened with the anti-tax movement
where the Democrats by 2001
found themselves voting
for tax cuts that nobody
would have taken seriously
even six or seven years before
such as the repeal of the estate tax.
So the Democrats left any
alternative geopolitical strategy
to the Bush doctrine.
The Bush doctrine filled a
void and they just ran with it.
And so one might think that
once 2008 rolled around
and the Democrats were again in control,
things might have played out differently.
But we'll see next time
that that's not how history played out.
We'll see you then.
(calm music)